sembra strano ma anche se sono ritornato
a casa in italia già da alcuni mesi devo
ancora rendermi conto veramente della
portata del viaggio che ho vissuto è più
che altro nello specifico devo ancora
metabolizzare le cifre di questa mia
avventura 4.300 chilometri a piedi
sei nazioni attraversate 84 giorni
avventurosi nove paia di scarpe
moltissime notti passate in tenda nei
boschi e pochissimi invece in un letto
offerto più di 50 km di media
giornaliera correndo e moltissimi
animali selvatici incontrati ecco questo
resoconto può sembrare è frutto di un
professionista è di un corridore di un
avventuriero professionista cosa che mi
permetto io non sono assolutamente
oppure di un passo magari categoria
nella quale mi vedo già già meglio però
scherzi a parte io devo dirvi che sono
invece un ragazzo normale ma oltretutto
fino a tre anni fa posso dire di essere
stato normalissimo e infatti non sapevo
nemmeno cosa volesse dire corre per più
di un'ora di fila
io giocavo a calcio andavo
all'università
avevo il mio lavoretto avevo la mia
fidanzata la mia cerchia di amici quindi
un quadro abbastanza normale ma allo
stesso tempo idilliaco che ahimé è
cambiato comunque in un certo verso è
andato in frantumi precisamente nel
settembre 2012 è la mia vita è cambiata
in maniera radicale non perché ho vinto
un qualche jackpot cose simili ma ahimè
perché ho avuto è un grave incidente
stradale
infatti mentre ero in moto una macchina
anni ha investito portandomi due gravi
lesioni a entrambe le gambe e un trauma
cranico e contusioni e abrasioni lungo
tutto il corpo che mi hanno purtroppo
costretto fermo a letto disteso per
circa sei mesi
ecco non vi nascondo che in un primo
momento ho dovuto affrontare una grave
crisi di depressione
infatti non avevo perso con questo
incidente solamente intera stagione
calcistica ma avevo perso anche il
lavoro dopo però questo primo momento
veramente ho deciso che questa pausa
anche se forzata doveva essere sfruttata
per un attimino guardarmi indietro nel
mio nel mio passato precedente e quello
però che stavo vedendo nel mio passato
non era una cosa felice non era un
quadro che mi piaceva non era
assolutamente contento di quello che
avevo costruito e quindi un bel giorno
ho deciso che quella seppur un'occasione
infelice sarebbe stato invece
l'occasione per ripartire più forte di
prima
ricordo ancora il giorno preciso è di
questa illuminazione quando passatemi il
termine correndo con le stampelle
sono sceso giù dalle scale e mi sono
piazzato davanti alla tavola dei miei
genitori mentre stavano cenando e
ricordo ancora queste parole papa mamma
io appena mi rimetto a posto fisicamente
partirò per un'avventura grandiosa della
quale sentirete parlare su tutti i
giornali subito mio parma ma si
guardarono con gli occhi sgranati e
depero la colpa probabilmente al trauma
cranico dell'incidente
però io in sordina sotto sotto
continuato a coltivare questa idea senza
mai mollare
e infatti è appena finita la
fisioterapia in soli tre mesi mi sono
ritrovato dal nulla da zero anzi da
sotto zero alla linea di partenza di
questa gara il magraid una 100
chilometri nella steppa friulana che non
solo sono riuscito a portare atene ma ho
portato a casa un granché un grandissimo
risultato in classifica inaspettato che
mi ha aperto le porte mi ha permesso di
continuare per tutte le tappe del
campionato italiano di questa categoria
di questa categoria è stato è stato
veramente veramente tosto e difficile
all'inizio ma anche se le montagne che
ho scalato con queste gare sono state
bellissime magnifiche non mi appaga vano
e ricorda invece anche un altro aneddoto
di un giorno preciso quando ho alzato la
cornetta chiamato allenatore diretto
ascolta senti a me queste gare non non
mi soddisfano più io voglio fare il giro
d'italia di corsa
lui si è dimostrato solo del subito
entusiasta di questo progetto però mi ha
dato una notizia al telefono che mi ha
subito tappato le ali infatti purtroppo
sfortuna ha voluto che un altro ragazzo
era proprio appena partito per fare il
medesimo giro d'italia sempre di corsa
anche se con modalità differenti ma
anche lì non non mi sono fatto
scoraggiare ricordo benissimo che sono
salito subito in camera appena ho messo
giù il telefono e o strotolato la
cartina dell'europa in cima alle preso
un compasso
ho puntato il compasso sul mio paesino
dagli era veneta e ho iniziato a
tracciare una circonferenza una
circonferenza però particolare che
avesse come raggio il chilometraggio
d'italia srotolato quindi circa 3.500 km
subito però nulla è lungo questa
circonferenza nessun paese nessuna città
attirò la mia attenzione ma appena a
spostare la mia attenzione la mia vista
leggermente più a nord in travi di un
punto che seppur non fosse una città o
comunque un paese molto noto era
comunque evidenziato è degno di nota per
la cartina geografica
a questo punto era capo nord ecco non
c'era bisogno di dire nient'altro per me
la mia avventura si stava già delineando
all'interno della mia testa e posso dire
di aver messo l'asticella molto molto in
alto per essere stata la mia prima
avventura il mio primo progetto
avventuroso infatti non solo questo
progetto aveva come avevo predefinito
mille chilometri praticamente in più del
progetto iniziale del giro d'italia ma
avevo preso anche una decisione molto
importante che per me era fondamentale
sarei stato completamente da solo in
questo viaggio e questo comportava due
cose essenzialmente la prima
di essere in completa autonomia quindi
ero costretto a costruire un carretto e
trainarlo perché all'interno doveva
sostenere tutti i miei beni di prima
necessità quali la tenda il fornello il
sacco a pelo eccetera e seconda cosa
invece che nei momenti di difficoltà
sarei stato completamente solo infatti
questa avventura si è differenziata da
molte altre
perché infatti non aveva un seguito non
avevo un cameraman non avevo un medico
non aveva un fisioterapista un cuoco che
mi seguisse
ecco è stata è stata veramente una
decisione bellissima e in poche
settimane perché comunque io dovevo
alternare e l'allenamento al lavoro sono
riuscito a raggiungere una preparazione
molto buona e finalmente e 19 aprile
2015 sono partito da dai era veneta sono
partito da venire avventa e la
previsione però era di arrivare circa a
ferragosto ma devo dire che l'entusiasmo
e la voglia di fare e fortunatamente le
mie gambe erano talmente buone che sono
arrivato un mese prima del previsto per
la precisione sono arrivato all 11
luglio infatti a casa grazie
infatti a casa stavano organizzando un
festone per ferragosto ma agli ho preso
in contropiede non abbiamo festeggiato
ed ecco questo mio percorso lo possono
tranquillamente raccontare non io e non
libri scritti eccetera ma lo possono
raccontare tranquillamente le nove paia
di scarpe che ho consumato qualche
qualche bellissimo incontro l'ho fatto
sicuramente durante il viaggio
e ricordo questo in particolare ovvero
nello specifico circa il nono giorno del
mio viaggio da rim ancora in bassa
baviera quando a bordo strada
incontrai un signore sulla settantina
che continuava a sbracciarsi ad attirare
la mia attenzione per invitarmi
all'interno di una stazione di servizio
solo che una volta dentro lui non
parlava inglese e non parlavo il tedesco
quindi la conversazione non stava
partendo fino a quando però lui dalla
giacca non estrasse un articolo
ingiallito questo articolo ingiallito
diceva che lui negli anni 60 aveva
costruito un carretto quasi uguale al
mio
ed era andato fin in danimarca a piedi è
stato bellissimo come uno sconosciuto
quando aveva capito che io avevo
compreso la sua storia che anche lui
aveva avuto l'opportunità di vivere il
sogno nella vita mi ha abbracciato ed ha
iniziato a piangere e lui e oltretutto
era c'è ancora
e oltretutto come uno sconosciuto
credeva veramente anche senza conoscermi
che io avrei portato a termine questa
avventura difficilissima invece potete
benissimo immaginare cosa pensavano i
miei concittadini nel mio piccolo
paesino quando mi vedono e mi vedevano
sfrecciare avanti indietro trainando
questo carretto pieno di pesi e
oltretutto quando mi fermavano per
chiedermi cosa stavo che diavoleria
avessi mente io rispondevo che mi stavo
allenando non per vincere una gara ma
per mollare il lavoro per mollare tutto
e per attraversare l'europa di corsa
ecco ero diventato un po il passo del
villaggio però anche qui non ho mai non
ho mai mollato la presa sul mio sogno è
però devo essere sincero quando dico che
sono stati fortunatissimi invece quando
ho proposto questo mio progetto
ai miei genitori alla mia fidanzata in
allenatore
ecco loro non si sono mai permesso di
dirmi che io ero passo che dovevo
mettere la testa a posto che dovevo
continuare a fare una vita normale e a
trovarmi un lavoro sicuro e anima nere
qui tranquillo
questo è stata veramente una spinta
emotiva che mi ha permesso di tagliare
il traguardo alla fine un altro tornando
sempre viaggio però un altro aneddoto
bellissimo è stato in una giornata in
svezia quando dopo qualche decina di
chilometri incontra in questo cartello
ecco
per pronunce non so quanti quanti
scandinavi ci siano dentro però per un
italiano ovviamente leggere la parola
dio è incorniciato oltretutto da questo
questo meteo che è impossibile da
trovare nella primavera svedese ve lo
assicuro poteva solamente che
preannunciare una giornata di via ca
stupenda fortunata e io avevo percepito
questa cosa avevo aumentato l'andatura
fino però dopo qualche decina di
chilometri un bullone spesso come il
dito di una mano ci tranciò di netto la
ruota proprio andrò da un'altra parte io
il carretto da un'altra e rimasi lì
fermo impalato a bordo strada per circa
tre ore e mezza prima che passasse
solamente un pensionato in bicicletta
che fortunatamente si è dimostrata avere
buon cuore perché poi è ritornato
indietro in macchina mi ha riportato a
casa sua e abbiamo aggiustato il
carretto con un dado un bullone di una
fresa agricola gli ho detto te fare a
meno di taglia l'erba per un po di tempo
ma almeno io arrivo a capo nord e il
carretto
scherzi a parte avevo un nome si
chiamava anna genni 1 è stato un nome
molto pensato e scelto da me interamente
perché anna è il nome della mia
fidanzata
jenny invece è il nome della fidanzata
di forrest gump nel film esatto che chi
l'ha visto
chi l'ha visto che l'ha visto il film
non può non ricordarselo e invece e
invece il numero uno stava dedicare la
mia speranza che questo non fosse
solamente la prima avventura di tante
formanti durante la mia vita
ecco questo carretto devo essere sincero
è stato il mio compagno di viaggio
effettivo per 84 giorni abbiamo fatto di
quei discorsi filosofici assieme
soprattutto in lapponia che che non
vinca non sto qui a dirvi però devo
anche ammettere seriamente che è stata
allagata più grossa da pelare durante il
mio viaggio infatti di tutta la totalità
delle 84 giorni 12 sono dovuto rimanere
fermo per aggiustare le sue tre rotture
cioè io ho le mie gambe non si sono
rotte ma si è rotto tre volte il
carretto
ecco ricordo ancora quando la prima
rottura ero incazzatissimo ho chiamato
il mio amico in italia che me lo aveva
saldato gli ho detto ascolto coma cos'è
che che lavora il fatto perché sei
partito io avevo mi ha confessato che ha
fatto questo lavoro con leggerezza
perché pensava che la mia fosse una
ragazzata che alla fine io non fossi
nemmeno partito e quindi è stato
veramente da strapparsi i capelli con
questo carretto però siamo siamo ancora
amici è tornato a casa con me non ho
lasciato la e devo dire anche sempre
tornando al viaggio che fino a metà
svezia il viaggio è stato c abbastanza
faticoso ma è stato divertentissimo e
umana dal punto di vista umano stato
molto formante perché ho incontrato
persone che davvero mi raccoglievano
dalla strada e mi evitavano per una
doccia calda un letto oppure anche
solamente del cibo e mi accoglievano in
casa quindi è stato veramente fantastico
però devo ammettere che appunto è in un
bel giorno più precisamente proprio il
giorno del mio compleanno il 15 giugno
il mio viaggio è cambiato completamente
è cambiato completamente quando
incontrato questo cartello l'inizio
della lapponia li posso dire che
veramente era finito il mio viaggio ed è
iniziata la mia avventura infatti da qui
in poi per circa due settimane ho dovuto
lavarmi solamente nei fiumi nei laghi
perché non ho trovato alcuna struttura
per potermi ricevere e ho dovuto
stracaricare il carretto fino a farlo
pesare 40
con viveri acqua e cibo perché c'era
anche una festa di mezzo nazionale e
avevo trovato veramente tutto chiuso per
due settimane
voi subito di rete si caspita andrea
questa qui allora è stata la parte più
dura più massacrante del tuo viaggio e
posso dire di sì perché qui ci sono
arrivato abbastanza allenate lappone
riuscivo a fare anche 70 chilometri al
giorno trainando 40 kg però devo anche
dire che oltre alla fatica fisica fisica
è stato il momento del viaggio più
formante e dove ho maturato i pensieri
più profondi dove ho trovato l'essenza
del vero andrea per esempio ho capito la
comprensione veramente di potercela fare
anche se siamo da soli in qualsiasi
situazione
quando siamo messi alle strette oppure
che una motivazione ben radicata come la
mia possa farci superare barriere ed
ostacoli che la società odierna continua
costruirci ogni giorno attorno ma
soprattutto ho imparato a ridare a
rifare a ricreare una scala completa di
valori che poi dal viaggio ho riportato
nella mia vita quotidiana infatti
fidatevi che dopo aver corso 70 km
magari sotto l'acqua
io non vedevo l'ora di sentire la voce
della mia fidanzata non vedevo l'ora di
bermi una birra e mangiare una buona
pizza o o di dormire a caldo nella mia
tenda non magari come quando era a casa
lì tranquillo che vedevo l'ora come
tutti i ragazzi e al giorno d'oggi di
prendere in mano il telefonino di andare
a fare un giro un po di festa o di
vestire degli abiti firmati
ecco questa scala adesso l'ho riportata
nella vita di tutti i giorni e vi dico
che funziona veramente non solo a capo
nord funziona che qui in italia però
quando sono arrivato invece devo
ammettere che ho scoperto una vera
verità ovvero che stava commettendo un
errore davvero davvero grosso prima di
partire
infatti mi sono reso conto che prima
dell'incidente stavo andando ad
occuparmi una posizione ad incasellarmi
su una posizione su una cella già
predefinita da qualcun altro e
soprattutto dalla società e stavo
seguendo questo percorso per andare a
sedermi su questa sedia non tracciato da
me invece
con l'incidente prima e con il viaggio
poi mi sono reso conto di essere unico
al mondo e di avere la possibilità di
tracciare veramente il percorso della
mia vita
quindi vi auguro davvero innanzitutto
anzi vi consiglio prima di almeno una
volta nella vita fermarvi a riflettere
perché viviamo in una società talmente
frenetica che non ce lo permette ovvio
che non vi auguro di stare sdraiati in
convalescenza sei mesi e non eletto come
come ho fatto io però è invece auguro
tutti prima o poi di poter vivere almeno
una volta nella vita il vostro sogno nel
cassetto io mi reputo davvero
fortunatissimo perché ho vissuto un
sogno lungo 84 giorni grazie